johnson has named their replacements
education secretary nadim zahawi takes
rishi sunak's position as chancellor of
the exchequer and the prime minister's
chief of staff steve barclay replaces
sajid javid as health secretary
a number of junior ministers have also
stepped down saying the prime minister
is unfit to govern rory challenge
reports
a double bombshell for britain's
scandal-blighted prime minister and one
that he'll need all his famous survival
skills to pull through from
the resignations of two of his most
important ministers came with personal
attacks that could prove politically
fatal
first out was health secretary sajid
javid with a judgment that the
conservative party had lost the faith of
the electorate it's clear to me that
this situation will not change under
your leadership he wrote and you have
therefore lost my confidence too
sticking the knife in shortly after was
chancellor rishi sunak the public
rightly expect government to be
conducted properly competently and
seriously i believe these standards are
worth fighting for and that is why i am
resigning peppered with questions as he
arrived home sajid javid used every
resigning politician's favorites no
comment cliche i'm just gonna go spend
some time with my family thank you for
coming
thank you
partygate the owen paterson affair the
downing street flat refurbishment
numerous scandals have brought the prime
minister to this point but what
seemingly precipitated these big
desertions is the admission from number
10 that johnson did know of a disgraced
mp chris pincher's previous sexual
assault allegations despite claiming he
didn't
minutes before his ministers walked mr
johnson went on tv to apologize i think
it was a mistake and i apologize for
uh
for it i think in in hindsight it was
the wrong thing to do i apologize to
everybody who's been badly affected
by it and i just want to make absolutely
clear that there's no place in this
government for
anybody who uh is predatory or who
abuses their position of power
the big question is of course what next
although there have been several further
junior resignations the rest of the
cabinets are sticking by their leader
for now at least
given johnson survived a vote of
confidence last month disgruntled mps
would have to change the rules to hold
another one within a year
opposition leader kier starmer is
calling for elections we need a fresh
start for britain
we need a change of government and this
government is collapsing the tory party
is corrupted and changing one man at the
top of the tory party won't make any
difference he won't fix the problems
let's have a fresh start for britain
let's have a real change of government
but at the moment that looks like a long
shot as does any expectation that boris
johnson will follow his ministers and
resign rory challenge al jazeera